hello everyone today I would like to
show you a game played between Michael
Dahl and his teacher Alexander Koblenz
it was played in Riga in 1957 and the
reason I like this game so much is that
it's extremely complicated it's it's
complicated even for towel standards so
let's see this game Mikkel tile is white
and all counter Koblenz is black so top
lazy for c5 Knight to f3 d6 the Sicilian
defence
d4c captures on d4 Knight captures on d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 Knight to c6
we have Bishop to g5 e six winter d2 all
standard theory Bishop 37 queenside
castle King set Castle Knight to b3
Queen to b6 f3 a6 g4 tower goes for that
King side attack rook to d8 Bishop d3
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 not all
plays h4 commands plays b5 and although
this game is extremely complicated and
it's a wonderful game this is actually
where the fun starts
so Tom plays g5 he kicks the Knight to
d7 and now if you look at this position
Tull is ready to play for that King side
attack and koblan's is ready to go for
the Queen side attack and the most of
the players here well they would play
they would like to play h5 and then play
g6 and well black is ready to play d4
and so this is my favorite move of the
game and top plays g6 immediately
without going for h5 first and he
sacrifices the phone just to make his
attack happen a little bit faster so we
have g 6h captures in g6 and now h5 so
we have G takes on h5 rook takes on h5
and Knight to f6 rook to h1 and it's all
sacrifice a pawn but he has an open H
file so
KaBlam plays d5 he wants to open up the
center but more importantly he's
protecting this h2 square so tile can't
put a screen and h2 but here Tao plays
another towel move and it lazy 5 he
closes up this protection of the queen
of the h2 square but this attack this
pawn can be captured so compliance plays
nice casters on e5 but let's see what
happens if you play Queen captures on e5
if Queen captures on e5 then ripped a
bishop to f4 attack the Queen Queen has
to go to f5 now Bishop to d3 attacking
the Queen again and after Queen goes to
g6 simply disrupt g1 well you simply
don't want to play this position against
McHale tau
so after this 'if I've move Coburn's
decided to capture this pawn with a
knight so nice captures e5 towel plays
Bishop to f4 we have Bishop to d6 and
now Queen to h2 so for the price of
another pawn a towel now has his both
rock and queen on the edge file and he
is present in checkmate on h8 so
koblan's plays King to f8 and Todd plays
Queen to h8 check and this is another
critical position of the game as it open
is in 12 games there are more critical
positions not only one in this position
if koblan's played something like King
to e7 he would be much better for
example if he's attacking health queen
now and if stall would play something
like for example Queen to H 2 then this
would be deadly Knight to b3 check after
roof captures this bishop would fork the
king in Queen
so after king 37 this Queen doesn't have
a lot of places she can go which you
could go to maybe h4 this would probably
be the best Square for her but after
that and Bishop e7 welcome Blanca Blanca
will be ok and he would be two pawns up
but by this stage of the game Tao
already got into Cullen's head and in
here Coburn's played nice to g8 and
hopefully it worked
seven we have s five because now solid
threatening to capture this pawn on g7
with checks so could one place the five
protecting in this point with the Queen
and Tao brings another piece into this
deck he plays Bishop to h6 the bishop
can't be captured because the night well
he spins from the Queen and if this pawn
captures it then
well the queen is going down so come on
plays route 37 protecting that g7 born
and here Collins has a very strong
threat if tall place a floor move
Coburn's will put this night here on g6
and he will try to adult queen but now
of course
so everything and he plays Bishop to b5
and this is a once more critical
position in the game
so obviously the commands can play
nicely g6 and trapped south queen but
let's see what Saul had in mind if God
wants plays this if Knight to g6 then
simply night to d4 and if compliance
capture spells Queen then Knight goes
here on e6 checking the kingdom for King
the Queen into f7 we have nice capture
screen and c7 rooks captures on c7 and
now row captors on g6 g7 we have Kim to
e6 if the King goes to f8 then Powell
will capture this work with an open
check from the bishop on e6 rook to e1
check King to f6 and Knight to d5
checkmate so playing playing that Knight
to g6 move would be a would be a mistake
so come on try the rook to f7 but here
top plays rook to g1
I'm going for the g7 pawn again we have
rook to a7 and here
Knight to d4 we have Knight to g4 KaBlam
gives back then the beasts and he is
hoping to close this file for the rook
so tell captures and the coolants plays
Bishop to e5 now protecting the g7 pawn
with the bishop as well
towel plays Knight to c6 attacking the
rook and the bishop
we have Bishop captures on c3 and now
I'll place Bishop to e3 now with a
double attack on this rook on a seven
we have d4 closing that bishops diagonal
and the metal plays rook G to H one and
now this is again a very powerful threat
if black plays something like for
example Bishop capturing the bishop on
b5 then that would simply capture the
night here with the Queen and the Queen
cannot be taken because this would be
well checkmate so after this rogue G th
one Coburn's plays rook back to d7 and
topless Bishop to g5 we had a capture
some b5 and style plays rook to h6
Coburn's plays v3 style plays be taken C
3 we have D 2 tau plays Kings to d1 and
now the Queen captures the knight on c6
but this is a well all over tau plays
rook to f6 check the rogue can be
captured with the night so : plays rook
to f7 covering up and here tau simply
captures Queen captures and g7 and well
in this position Coblentz resigned and
well the student has surpassed the
teacher in this position is act is
actually a force to mate in nine but
while playing all the knight moves would
be silly as we have well King 37 we have
rook captures on f7 and now tall is
threatening to capture this nice with
the Queen to checkmate the black King
so black would have to play something
like Queen f3 checks and after King to
d2 Queen G to check in to see one going
to f1 check and King to beat - and there
are no more checks and well in a couple
of moves black will fall so yeah this is
also one of my favourite games played by
Michael towel and it's a very
very symbolic that it was against his
teacher and like I hope you enjoyed it
and well I will put the begin of the
game in the description below so you can
analyze all the variations for yourself
I didn't analyze all the variations
because there are simply too many of
them so yeah that's it for the game I
hope you will be able to attend my chest
quiz today and you know try to win that
nice chess set and for those of you who
won't be able I hope you will maybe be
able to attend some other time and as
usual here you can check to my previous
videos and I'll see you soon and if you
really enjoyed this game feel free to
share it with your friends so they can
enjoy it as well see you soon